Hi, Marvel fans.
I'm here with Arian Moayed.
How's it going?
How are you feeling?
I am feeling
overwhelmed, excited.
I cannot wait to see
it on a big screen.
I'm, like, over the moon
about this whole thing.
How does it feel to
be a part of the MCU?
It's surreal.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
It's completely surreal
to be a part of Marvel.
You know, I was born in Iran.
And so to have that
be from there to here
is a real surreal moment for me.
So I really, really--
you know, I'm just honored
and blessed, really.
Oh, that's so good to hear.
Well, I'm excited for you.
What are you looking forward
to most in the film tonight?
I am looking forward to--
selfishly, I'm looking forward
to my interrogation with Ned.
[LAUGHS] Spoiler.
INTERVIEWER: OK, OK.
But most of what I'm
really looking forward to
is watching Tom
Holland and watching
all these folks make
these amazing human beings
come to life.
I mean, that's what
I'm looking forward to.
I mean, this is big.
This film, everyone
knows who Peter
Parker's secret identity is.
It's Spider-Man.
How does your character
feel about that?
Obviously, he-- he's
interrogating him.
So he comes in and really
interrogates the group
and really kind of tells
them, listen, you shouldn't
have done that, you know.
Anyway, I'm really just
excited to be here and be
a small part of this movie.
[MUSIC PLAYING]